bà đồ phán
tính giúp
là phải đồ phán về thế chế
đây là công việc của chúng ta đại của đang tích cực chân khai
tần tật chúng không phục ngay như thế xa
thì nó sót cho các quy định của phóc lợn
và quy định của đàn
để không chức vợn lỗi chức kêu chế phóc lợn
khi sẽ giang vi phán
và một đồ lỗi hi hai là vào cái này thì
có làm quán
không làm được
không giám làm
ai thì mặt nó
đều không không hành
phải không phục cửa những cái
bây giờ quán lý thì nào không hành cái tần giám làm gì
là để cho ăn toàn
thế thì cũng chạp
kêu cầu đời nào là phải đàn bảo
thông tháng, có chỉ chính xe khách phát triển
nhưng phải kiểm sob
trách chạm biết chạm
nhất là hoàn thiệt
các cơ chế kiểm chà 3 3 của đàn
thêm chạm kiểm toán của nhà nước
không để phát triển
tham giúp nghe là phí từ cửa
đồng thầy của phải sống hoàn thiện
bộ chỉ số đến giáng
hiệu quà cũng thấp phần chúng
tham giúp lệng phí từ cửa
ám dục thống nhất trong cả đợp
phải chỉ gió điện trị kiếu cám
hồi trị trị hiểm
trong các cộng đặt này
thứ 2 là phải đồ phó án về cũng thật cám bộ
tập trung trên khai khó hiệu quà
các quý định mới của chính trị là cũng thật cám bộ
xích chạm
bị lật trị cơ
băng cường quán lý
giám xác cám bộ
kinh cứu lại mò
bộ mấy những cám bộ
tham giúp lệng phí từ cửa đùn đầy
hẹn chẳng xanh hiểm
không giám lạng
mùi cám bộ nào vuyện
nhất là người đứng đầu
các cơ quý
phải hương mộ
tựa xác khác mình vào tổ chức
tôn thủ các quý định
vừa đoạn hiểm cám dộ
nhận thực rất giòn
công quý là của dân
công quen là vì dân
để quay xuất pháp từ dân
vì dân không được quý dân từ
không làm hình ưởng đến điểm tiên
bất kỳ ai
hình quý tham giúp lạng phí
điều cửa khảm chờ
đối mối
khảm chờ
sự phát triển của rất thơ
không chỉ có lộ rất lớn
mà không có tốt
với đàn
nhận nước
ở nơi dân
mà chắc chẳng sẽ bị xử
nghiêm khách
của bà
đối phá
với những dụng quà không nè ở chuyển bộ số
mà không khai mình bài
chắc nhận giải trình
tập trung xây dựng chính quyền số
sau số
không ra số
hoàn thiện cơ sở giữ liệu
mở giống
nó đơn đẹp tự
lấu thàu đủ
ra không khai chiến định tặng số
kìm xóc lại sản thung nhập mình không nè
có cơ chế lộ trình bò ra
mưng bài tài sản
nhưng tòn xa rồi
để mạnh thánh toán không dùng tìm mà
điểm sắp càng tư dòng dịch lớn
ngoại thúng gần hàng
cơ hoàn cũng cóm được cơ sử công
còn hình thức trực tuyến công khai
quy trình thời hạn
ghi phí
ra không tối đàn
được gần bộ xuân nhập
được xúc phát cán bộ
để giải quyết các nếu thụ tục của hành trình